how's the gum presence boat welcome back
to our
[Music]
anything cool requires level 10 we're
gonna get there today bros oh my god I
could make a seder all along what that a
feel movius able oh my god
alright that's what we're doing next
we're not doing anything else except
staring at my camel toe I mean except
dad right now
how do we build it how do we do it it's
probably just a lot of skin yeah a lot
of skin and a lot of fiber I died I
think last time did I die again I don't
remember I don't I blocked it out of my
memory okay we're back in action baby we
got all our tools never gonna write that
dinosaur say it with me bros say it say
it with me please are we gonna do are we
gonna do what are we gonna do what are
we gonna do
say it that's right
I'm not gonna ride you goddamn you're
disgusting
[ __ ] weird-ass tumblr girlis man Oh
what is that sound first time I kill
these I was so sad now I'm just [ __ ]
[ __ ] psycho where do you go give me
your skin oh nice a lot of skin I love
when they have a lot of skin whoa look
at the moon that's amazing okay now we
just need to kill a [ __ ] ton of dinosaur
and then we're gonna ride a dinosaur and
then we win the Internet
oh my [ __ ] god what the [ __ ] are you
where's your hands what the [ __ ] is act
are you stuck in the pooper what is he
doing haha are you doing is it going
what is this I think he's stuck you
[ __ ]
take some of this and somebody else and
someone else and some of this dance for
me girl dance oh dance for me girl dance
oh why would you die oh my god don't
worry breast I got a plan I just [ __ ]
myself that's the plan we're gonna kill
this [ __ ] and we won't even tell his
wife bet you wish you weren't stuck now
[ __ ] [ __ ] head shot that [ __ ]
please oh come on this is for all the
times you [ __ ] me over
why won't you just die yeah who's your
boss yeah oh my god I feel like I should
use this to tame it but I'm too pissed
well mate oh my god die already
there you go oh so much skin
yes oh I can feel it I feel I feel more
powerful I feel like I got superpowers
that was [ __ ] amazing I feel so
empowered as a woman right now Bros you
have no [ __ ] idea the [ __ ] was that
equip FIO Mia with this to ride it what
the [ __ ] is a farm oh yeah are you
familiar I thought these were from oh
yes that's a para ser hour it's still a
shame how [ __ ] bad this game runs
like Jesus Christ I have a pretty good
computer it's not right tree isn't that
right oh my god I take back everything
I'm sorry tree Oh awesome
the [ __ ] is that sound
oh my god calm down [ __ ] hell Tina I
love fans Jesus Christ you're a master
climber Tina that's right [ __ ] shut the
[ __ ] up just [ __ ] die
thank you so brutal oh my god oh my god
haha yeah you go girl I like to party I
like to move it I like to dance ass
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] make out with it go I'll
make out me to yoga I love a big fan my
ovaries are [ __ ] exploding I'm done
alright we really need to eat let's slap
this [ __ ] oh that's a weird dinosaur
I've never seen that before
is that is that the Fonua pardon me sir
are you a vanilla must contain the best
contain okay all right ass shot asks
where the [ __ ] are you running you
[ __ ] idiot
did he just run straight inside a rock
this is like the next Miley Cyrus video
[ __ ] hell I didn't even ask for this
alright
I did not you made this sexual I did not
arretez your oncologist now mate alright
it says here in my brain purpleberries -
I'm guessing are these mate I'm going
chicken on you in a bit this is so much
fun this is so much fun I'm having fun
lots of fun would you you her and I have
fun let's go on a run [ __ ] that [ __ ]
actually let's just play video games
that's a good song where are their
[ __ ] purple berries
you promised me purple berries now how
the [ __ ] do I find whatever ass is stuck
inside a mountain
why I don't I don't remember oh my god
where is the ass come on [ __ ] oh my
god seriously
I don't find the [ __ ] oh there it is
tiny little [ __ ] let's give him narco
berries
it's really taming slowly sitting the
Tinto berries all right I don't have
time for this
what the actual [ __ ] is going on here oh
my god it's a gangbang a fish bang a
gang fish I don't what the [ __ ] are they
doing they're climbing a top of each
other all right you know what I'm gonna
explore this [ __ ] hey fishies hello
maybe I can kill one of them or some
[ __ ] hey fish oh god oh god
turn it around ah no ah ah you know
shoosh shoosh shame on you shame on all
right [ __ ] it you know what I'll have to
end this episode I'll write the [ __ ]
dinosaurs when I live my life bro sings
you're watching stay awesome